please giving us some timings now this
is what we know a man has been arrested
after three people were found dead in
the city he's been arrested on suspicion
of murder please call to the ilkston
road area just after 4 a.m where two
people were found dead in the street
officers were then called to another
incident in Milton Street where a van
had attempted to run over three more
people they are currently being treated
in hospital a man has also been found
dead in magdala Road police have
arrested a 31 year old man on suspicion
of murder and he remains in police con
police custody Chief Constable Kate
mainel said this is horrific tragic
incident which has claimed the lives of
three people we believe these three
incidents are all linked and we have a
man in custody